it's something I got and I'm sure you've
gotten this to is like hey I'm starting
a video essay channel tell me what you
think how shall I start and what I
always say and this is really what I
believe is not only just start but
really try to try to finish something as
quickly as possible that you like you
like and it's the best you probably
could have done in maybe three to five
days or something like that and just
iterate upon it because no matter how
much time you spend on it you're gonna
look back and even a month and you're
gonna just cringe at it
yeah and that's okay because that's just
that's part of it is that what you say
as well I I would I whenever I get an
email asking for advice about starting a
channel especially video si s channel is
simply you just have to start doing it
because as soon as you you know go
through the process that's how you learn
in the process I think I've told you
this story which is that the teacher and
the ceramic product tell it again I love
it I love it yes so right so it's the
beginning of the semester and the
teacher divides the classroom to on the
left side she says this half of the
class you're going to be graded based on
the weight of your pots so at the end of
the semester you know those with forty
pounds get an A 30 pounds B et cetera
this other half of the class is going to
be judged on one perfect pot and you
know that is all you get you get one pot
so the semester goes on half the class
is making as many as they can
the other is theorizing theorizing how
am I gonna make this one pot perfect at
the end of the semester the guys who
made all the quantity had the best pots
because these people started and only
made one they didn't have enough trial
and error to make a perfect pot so the
guys who made the weight also made the
quality ones right so I think that's
just a great analogy of you just have to
keep doing it
and as you trial-and-error you start to
realize who this part of the process is
not streamlined it's not good oh this is
how you make this more visually
appealing oh this is a better way to
edit my audio you just have to keep you
know trial and error things and
eventually you're gonna get there that's
literally all it is and it's all it is
but it's not intuitive when you haven't
done it before right and that's what I
think people get hung up on is they do
think that like I can perfectly craft if
I just think hard enough about it if I
just do it enough and yeah so that's I
think it's really important lesson
[Music]